[Music]
hi yes I am Lucy and I'm here to talk
about my team's work so my team is
called conversation AI and so some of
the things I'm going to talk about our
first of all I'll just give you some
context on who we are what jigsaw is
what is our team do what do we build and
then I'll kind of go into a couple
different examples of how we're thinking
about ethics in our data practices and
in our product and specifically with
respect to mitigating bias okay so
jigsaw is unit within Google within an
alphabet and we're building technology
to make people safer and it's a range of
different things research products
thinking about digital attacks online
harassment extremism etc many different
things my team focuses on the online
harassment and hate portion so that's
what we'll talk about here not going to
talk about any of the rest of this stuff
okay so conversation AI is the name of
my team's effort
our mission is protect voices in
conversation and we do a range of
different things we build API we do
research we build tools around our API
and perspective is the name of our API
which is really our flagship product so
what what does that mean
like what is protecting voices in
conversation mean so we're thinking
about how abuse hate toxicity in online
conversation is actually forcing people
out platforms are shutting down their
comments section people are just saying
like I do not want to have a
conversation on the Internet and
specifically voices are being silenced
people are not able to communicate and
people are forced to talk only it's
really really hard to talk to somebody
maybe who you disagree with online so
that's the area that
working on those are the problems we're
trying to think about and so what are we
building we're building an API that
serves machine learning models to
recognize various types of conversation
that might actually be silencing people
or forcing people out of the
conversation so you can send us a piece
of text like this example we have up
here it's gonna go into our API and what
you're gonna get back our scores for
various different aspects of that text
there and so what I about those scores
what we're modeling here is the
emotional impact of that text so we'll
get to this later but people often use
this type of product to help their
moderators know where to look those
people are often enforcing a pretty
complicated policy that represents you
know this type of thing is what we are X
is acceptable in our platform this type
of thing is not and they're really
detailed and really complicated and very
hard to build machine learning models to
support those things so one of the core
insights that we have working with this
product is that all those policies are
actually based on human emotions they're
based on how is this gonna make somebody
feel if they see it on my platform and
that's actually much more Universal
people do have different feelings but
it's much easier to have crowd source
annotations people understand what you
mean when you say would you leave a
conversation if you saw this people
understand that concept and you can
actually annotate data and build models
off of that so that's exactly what we're
doing this question here on the bottom
is this a rude disrespectful or
unreasonable comment that would make you
want to leave a discussion that's what
we call toxicity and that's our main
model that we're working with and so
then on the team there's a little bit
about how we do our work we're really
operating all the way across the
spectrum from gathering data outputting
machine like doing machine learning
research and publishing papers building
a concrete API building tools on top of
that API and then working direct
with platforms that use our API and even
end users and people who experience
harassment online we really try to work
that whole spectrum and understand what
our impact is and where we can make a
difference so when we think about are we
being successful these are a couple
different metrics that we use thinking
about the participation in a
conversation how many people are able to
participate how diverse is that
conversation reducing the amount of
toxicity that's forcing people out of
the conversation and then this last one
action is thinking about how we as a
team have influence on the industry and
can influence the industry to take the
problems of online harassment more
seriously and respond even if they're
not using us to do so and so this is
values so when we started this effort we
actually sat down and set out a set of
values and when I say we I was not on
the team at this point so other people's
work community topic neutrality
transparency privacy inclusivity these
are all really vague they all are
occasionally in conflict and we actually
talk about that a lot in our work and we
sit down when we talk about a new
product or a new idea and think about
how does this you know reflect the value
of privacy and how can we think about
that in our work and and you you'll see
that as we're we're going through some
of the examples later on and this is
just more concretely how do people use
an API like this so moderation is the
kind of the most obvious one using the
an API to score comments coming in to
your platform and then have your human
moderators use that to sort how they
look at them know when to flag and
really point them to where their
expertise is needed but that's not the
only way you can use this
there's also authorship so this is as
somebody is typing a comment you can
give them a little heads up like this
might violate our Community Guidelines
or
our people often leave a conversation
when you say things like this and we've
actually studied this a little bit and
it matters a lot how you give this
message but people do react and it does
actually make a difference and we're
really excited to see that then we're
also thinking about readership or
viewership so imagine if you could give
control to somebody who is reading
comments and allowed them to make a
decision or even you can visualize
different trends and study the
conversation okay so now I'm gonna go
into a couple little examples of how
we're thinking about some of those
values and and the work we've done
around them oh my if isn't working
okay there's a gif here but you can't
see it so we have a public demo if you
go to perspective API comm you can
actually see this what should be in this
box is somebody typing a nasty comment
and then you get back the perspective
score and so that's right there on our
website anybody can try it they don't
have to set anything up get access pay
any of those things and we found this to
be extremely valuable we're getting
we've we've actually had people will use
that and point out problems in our model
and it helps us improve there's even a
way where you can say hey this this
model score is wrong and we'll fix it
not immediately but we collect that
information we don't automatically train
on that data because we have seen people
come to this and try to train our models
incorrectly and give us bad data and in
fact if you just take that data and have
it relabeled by human annotators who you
trust
it's actually really fantastic data for
improving your product but I can't
stress enough how important it is to
have a way for anybody to spot check
what you're doing and and really
understand it's made our product a lot
better
and then another thing that we're
working on is the concept of model cards
so model card is documentation framework
that enables product to sort of document
how does their model work evaluation
results how is it meant to be used how
is it not meant to be used all of those
things so we have a version of this up
on our github it's very preliminary
right now I'm very kind of technically
raw but we're really excited to to
maintain this and build on it and think
about how can we just hold ourselves
accountable to sharing these results
repeatedly every time we make a model
update okay all right getting into the
meat here so thinking about unintended
bias so when we first launched the model
we had thought a bunch about unintended
bias to begin with and I won't cover too
much of what we did before only to say
that we didn't find unintended bias in
our model even though we were pretty
sure it was there we didn't know where
but through that demo that I showed you
right after our launch people pointed
out that we had problems like this so
what you're seeing here are several
comments that are not toxic at all
but use words like gay lesbian
transgender and Muslim names of identity
groups that are attacked frequently
online and our model thought that those
were toxic words and so what we did to
improve this is we actually looked at
the data that we trained on and we saw
that in fact for many of those words the
data set because it came from comments
online showed that those were toxic
words those identities were so
frequently attacked in online discussion
that the model the model was correct and
believing that they were offensive for
its for what it saw so we actually
needed to go outside of the domain of
online comments to make a difference
with this product with this problem so
we we added more training data and we
saw anecdotally from looking at how
I'm looking at the model like looking at
what score's got back it looked like it
was improving but we didn't actually
have a way to really measure this
concretely and test in a systematic way
we didn't have metrics we didn't have
data to test and so now I'm gonna dive
in to a little bit more technical stuff
about how we actually measure for
unintended bias and track how things are
changing so first of all what do we mean
when we say unintended bias here we're
talking about models performing
differently across different subgroups
and for us in this work when we say
subgroup we're talking about identities
that are being mentioned in the text we
could also be thinking about the
identity of the author of the comment
the identity of maybe the person who
wrote the article that the comment was
posted under we're not talking about any
of that today and then for us because we
have an API and people the way that
people use our API is very varied we
preferred metrics that were a threshold
of agnostic all right so so the AUC
probably most of you are already
familiar with this but we're gonna do a
little review so that we can go past it
so you see it measures how good is a
model at distinguishing toxic from non
toxic or positive from negative examples
so what you're seeing here in this chart
and then we're going to show a lot of
these charts so it's important to
understand them the so the x-axis here
is the model score and this is
essentially a histogram of how many
comments have approximately that score
red is the toxic comments in blue is the
non-toxic comments according to human
annotation so a model that looks like
this is not doing a very good job
separating toxic from non toxic so it's
gonna have a low AUC model that looks
like this is gonna have a high AUC may
be exactly one because there's a lot of
separation you can actually just draw a
line down the middle there and say this
is the division between toxic and non
toxic okay so now to measure for bias
we're thinking
the AUC metric but we're thinking about
it divided up across different identity
groups so we have and remember we're
talking about identities that are
mentioned in the comment so so on the
top you've got the background so all of
the data and on the bottom you've got
just the comments that are mentioning a
particular identity and so if and you
can see this is biased right this model
is performing differently for comments
mentioning a certain identity so we can
measure this type of bias by measuring
just the a you see on those comments
that mention the subgroup so we call
this metric subgroup a you see but this
doesn't capture all ways that a model
could be biased so what about something
like this where if you look just at the
comments that are mentioning a
particular identity you actually still
can separate between toxic and non toxic
just fine
but where there's a problem is that the
non toxic things that mention a certain
identity those are getting scores that
overlap with toxic things that don't
your scores are too high so you're gonna
get if you're measuring thinking about
false positives false negatives here
you're gonna get a lot of false
positives so for this we take the AUC of
just the background positive or toxic
things in the background section and the
subgroup negative top non-toxic things
in this up eating the subgroup identity
and we take the AUC of just those two
subsets of the data all right and now
the opposite so here we're thinking
about a type of bias where within the
identity sub group the scores are
shifted lower we call this background
positive subgroup negative ooh that's
incorrect sorry should be background
negative subgroup positive okay and so
we've got our three metrics subgroup a
you see and then the two kind of
crisscross au C's then we created a
synthetic dataset where we actually just
took templates
and swapped in different identity words
that we thought might be susceptible to
bias and so now we have a data set we
have metrics we can actually test and
see if that bias mitigation where we
added data we can see did that actually
help and so what you're seeing here I
know this is very hard to see but you're
seeing those three different metrics for
our first toxicity model and then our
latest toxicity model and the part
that's highlighted those are the
identity terms homosexual gay and
lesbian so what you see is there's an in
the basically the darker boxes those
represent low AUC scores and essentially
a high bias so you're seeing a lot and
that middle column that's the the one
indicating scores shifted higher so
we're seeing a lot of false positives
exactly what we saw in that original
example and what you see here is that it
actually did improve so we added data we
made an improvement so that's pretty
great we were pretty proud however so we
used that previous one that was on
synthetic data really really simple
template add sentences what we have here
and we decided we felt like some those
simple sentences were really helping us
evaluate but they obviously don't cover
everything so we in April we released a
data set of two million comments this is
completely public under Creative Commons
so please go use it and we annotated
this for toxicity as we usually do but
we also annotated for identity so we
actually asked human annotators what
genders are mentioned in this comment
what races are mentioned in this comment
and that gives us a way to do that same
type of division by subgroups mentioned
but not just focus on individual
identity words by selling them into a
template but actually look at the
overall concept so that means that
perhaps a comment talking about same-sex
marriage might be labeled by a human
is referencing the gay identity even if
it doesn't say the word gay so looking
at this data set we actually don't see
the same improvement that we saw so
these are the exact same models just
being tested on different data and the
results are much more confusing and you
do see some variation you do see that
there is a reduction in that middle
column in the identity labeled
homosexual gay or lesbian so any of
those identities mentioned in the
comment you do see a reduction in the
background positive subgroup negative or
kind of false positive metric but the
other ones also kind of some of them get
worse so much more mixed results here so
we dug into that to understand what was
going on and and what was the difference
between these two datasets why were we
seeing such a discrepancy and what we
ended up finding is that if you restrict
just down to short comments in the real
dataset you actually see that the
original model was performing even worse
on short comments so and we saw that
back I didn't go into it in the original
slide but we actually saw that when we
look at the data short comments that
contain identity words are
overwhelmingly toxic in online
conversation and so the model actually
learns according to length and so what
you're seeing here so this is showing
that the the problem was really really
bad for short comments and that
mitigation that we did all it did was
kind of bring short comments performance
in line with the overall performance but
it didn't generalize and it didn't make
an even broader improvement and so the
takeaway there is like there's a lot to
look at here there's a lot of different
ways you can look at your data and one
way is not enough and we're still kind
of digging into is this enough now how
do we want to prioritize that this data
set is public you all can poke at it I'm
going to talk a little more about it
but please do so this data set that we
used there we also released it in a cago
competition in April I don't know if
anyone participated in that competition
it's really fun so the data is all there
if you want to play with it what we
found so in order to do a competition
where you're measuring models for their
performance with respect to unintended
bias obviously you need a metric that
captures that so we took those three
metrics that we had in the that I showed
in the previous examples and we actually
calculate a generalized mean of those
three and then average that also with
the overall AUC to get away for
comparing models with respect to bias
and overall performance and I think that
is actually an area where we still would
like to do more research if anyone has
other ideas and ways to think about this
I think as I showed previously like one
data set isn't enough probably one
metric isn't enough so the concept of
comparing models and trying to have a
winner for at least bias is pretty
strange so thinking about how can we
actually do this in a competition format
or more importantly when you're choosing
for a product like what is the model
you're gonna serve it's pretty hard to
come up with the right metric and that's
an area we'd love to continue to talk
about and in terms of results from the
competition what we saw our one Bert is
killing everything it is it's the hero
every single winner used Bert and it
actually it almost like there weren't
other bias mitigation techniques that
outperformed just using birth basically
so that was pretty interesting to us the
one bias mitigation technique that
people did use was that they up weighted
data that mentioned identities in their
training so similar technique to what we
did which was going out and finding
additional data they just up weighted
the data that they had and all of the
winners did both of these things
all right questions annotation of the
pipeline truth so specifically like how
did you guys
Raiders to think about statistics
regarding my hair treatment often did
they agree how much of that was yeah so
the we did a lot of research on this
right when we were first getting started
and what I spoke about at the beginning
is that that question of would you leave
the conversation if you saw this that's
what we found worked best that's what
had the highest internat ATAR agreement
I actually don't have the numbers off
the top of my head but I can find them
and but we found that the more you try
to define it the less agreement there is
actually and that appealing to something
that that humans understand helps we
also do a lot of we don't ask just one
person and we at a very minimum three
people usually around ten people and we
do that to capture that subjectivity and
actually this is an area that we're kind
of moving to think about a bunch more is
not thinking about the annotators as
just like a black box all the same
person because they're not they're
individual human beings
so with that kaggle data in the coming
weeks we're going to be releasing as it
is right now what we have is the comment
and then the percentage of people who
said it was toxic we're gonna release
the actual annotator decisions so each
individual person's choice hoping that
you all will think about maybe there's a
better way to do it than just averaging
maybe you know some people are really
good at writing certain comments and we
can we can wait those differently so
that's an area where I'm really excited
to do more research
thank you for the talk I'm curious
whether you looked at
contextual like you know the the
previous and following comments around a
comment to kind of see the context that
a comment came within and whether that
has any bearing whatsoever on the yeah
so for the like the product perspective
as it is right now we don't so we're
just looking at the individual comment
we have done some research on that and
we're exploring it further the where we
are now is that it does matter the
previous comment matters the context of
the conversation it all matters in
specific scenarios so you know many
can't there are a lot of really simple
ways to be very toxic that are just
toxic most places you go and that's the
majority of what's out there on the
internet but there are specific
scenarios and I think a lot of what
we're researching now is is it possible
to narrow down to where context matters
and change our models in that way so
we're researching it right now
and hopefully that will change how we do
things in the future
yeah yeah so I don't know that's one
that's pretty hard to measure we've done
a little bit of research on it and I
think this is it's pretty similar to the
context question where for the majority
of comments out there the identity of
the annotator doesn't change what
they're gonna say but it's probably a
very specific minority of comments where
identity we're maybe not just identity
but an individual person's background
knowledge history etc matters and
changes who is most prepared to
accurately write a comment and I think I
get like this is something that we're
looking into researching in the future
and thinking about how do we best match
an annotator with the data that they are
best suited to right and because we
still don't know
it's very aligned with what you would
expect from society so identities that
are marginalized identities that get a
lot of attacks online that's where the
model is performing badly that's where
the model is confusing those identities
for toxicity and we do see a little bit
of the reverse so identities that are
generally in power sometimes the model
confuses those for lack of toxicity and
is bad at recognizing toxicity when
those identities are mentioned and so
it's it's actually like relatively
predictably aligned with the world
we've only done a little bit of research
on this and it's not my work so I hope I
get it right but what we have seen is
that so we haven't done it too much in
like as I answered previously we haven't
done a lot of modeling of an entire
conversation I'm thinking about how that
impacts bias but we definitely have seen
that toxicity does tend to escalate in
the conversation and that there are sort
of it might be possible to pinpoint like
a turning point somewhere in a
conversation where the toxicity is
starting to elevate but it's not quite
at the leave a conversation level some
more research needed there
yeah so everything here is English we
are really heavily invested right now in
building this out in many languages
I believe we're soon to share the
synthetic data sets in multiple
languages again like we are we're
building that pretty simply on our side
if there are you know lists of identity
terms out there in the world for
different countries that's input we
would love to have and we are searching
for but we're starting with what we can
get and I think we're also we'd also
love to internationalize this larger
data set so stay tuned there and if
anybody has like a large set of comments
in any language that they want us to
annotate we would love to do that
would be beyond the language but also
this cold
those regions yeah that ties in with the
research that were planning around how
did different individual people annotate
and what of their background matters for
how they make decisions definitely true
that different areas different countries
you know language isn't the only thing
that matters when we're thinking about
bias we also need to think about the
society and all of that is super
important and we are thinking about that
I had another point I was gonna say that
I forgot one of the really cool things
that's happening now is with Bert
there's a lot of work on multilingual
models and models working you know you
don't necessarily need a different model
to do multiple languages and so rather
than necessarily needing you know a
different model for each different
country that speaks to the same language
so an English model for the US an
English model for Australia one for the
UK etc hopefully my my hope is that if
we have representative data going into
that model from those different areas
that a single model might be able to do
a good job with those things and then of
course we need to do thorough evaluation
to spot check that it actually is but
that's my hope
comment and
that kind of question was that started
but yeah that we don't for perspective
as it is today but we have done some
research on it and and where that lessor
research is leading is that many cases
it doesn't matter but in a small set of
cases it does
yeah the I think that that's hard
because our you know often annotators
are not part of hate groups luckily and
so they don't always know that so I
think the the key for us is monitoring
finding out like where is that happening
and how do we spot it in our data you
know what and and make it like correct
it when maybe we don't necessarily
believe that the annotators will know
and be up to date with that language
we're definitely still working on like
how do we stay on top of that but my
hope is that similarly to how people use
identity words or even reclaimed words
that a single word can have many
different meanings
so taking one word and substituting it
out for another word a model can
understand that and it can understand
based on the rest of the sentence
whether you're trying to be hateful or
not even if it's a word that has many
different meanings it's a matter of
making sure that the input data to train
that model has the right labels and that
the humans who trained that model and
the annotators who created that data can
tell the difference themselves
[Applause]
we have not done that but perhaps
perhaps you could I think it is
definitely true that spoken language and
written language are different so I
wouldn't I think some folks actually
have tried running our models on
transcripts of various audio and you
know it'll find the really offensive
stuff if it gets transcribed correctly
and that's another I used to work on
speech recognition and sidebar but they
like for speech recognition it's a
really big problem if you say something
offensive that the person speaking
didn't say if you transcribe something
offensive that wasn't what was intended
so the recognition is always going to
are on the side of a less offensive
statement same with machine translation
so when we incorporate those models into
what we're doing we actually can miss
things if they get lost in the
transcription or the translation
[Music]